you are like the son I never heard but  much prettier hey Shekhar why don't you  pick on someone your own size there's no  one that big man mr Dunne mr. Collings I  know you I saw you with the Volunteer  Center I wanted to help well I hope you  don't mind me coming by I got your  address from this letter that you wrote  my wife yeah you said that hop what are  you doing what do you want her you won't  sit here and hold this crossroad all  phases but you know saw what i want to  do with what we're doing five of us is  everybody position mana fighting  positions when we ain't gotta tell you  how we gonna fight we are guerlain  yo always seek  the chair  I don't see anything guys I think we  should get out of here run